coming up on 5 26 on your wednesday  morning got a viewer with plenty on his  mind when it comes to driving habits on  the 215 beltway victor writes the 215 is  not a speedway but at least on a  speedway everyone knows how to drive  since they're professionals no trucks  everyone's concentrating only on driving  and he adds the left lane is for passing  not parking at 65 miles an hour if you  want to drive at speed limit stay in the  center lane blocking faster drivers  doesn't make it safer on the contrary it  creates road rage you want to control  traffic become a cop  all right victor i can almost hear the  cheering from other viewers who  wholeheartedly agree with you well i'm  hopeful that we can all get to a place  where everyone does the right thing and  we all get where we're going safely  buckle up drive carefully please put  down that phone something's driving you  crazy email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com